hey guys what's up this is andrew from
transitions.com so in this video i would
like to talk about two very hot stocks
that everybody is discussing on my
discord and that had very nice moves up
yesterday i'm talking here about any and
btcm so let's get into it
[Music]
all right so let's start with any so
here i'm gonna go with you through the
entire analysis of the chart so
technical analysis and i will as well
combine this
with the information i have from the
option market as i am
a next option trader i know how to read
this data and how to get information
from it so let's start with any so we
are on a daily time frame we can see we
have a very strong downtrend that ended
up
here all right so we went so to 0.3 so
the stock almost was bankrupt i guess
and then after the crisis we have here a
strong breakout so the first thing when
you identify such a breakout so guys
here very important logarithmic scale
all right otherwise the chart doesn't
make any sense once you have located a
breakout the first thing you do always
so keep this in mind you put a trendline
on the breakout level okay you try to
match some highs that would be false so
here i don't have a clear
i would maybe have it here but the
breakout is slightly higher so you know
i should have put it here but here i can
see i have a low here and low here so
i'm gonna match the lows and matching
the breakouts not too bad so
now
what do we have this stock woke up here
then corrected all right
fair enough and
in may so three four months ago it
started to rally uh very strongly so it
took well 500 all right and i was here
saying that i don't have the breakouts
yet that it looks good okay now if we
zoom in because everybody was talking
about the stock here here we have a nice
uh cap and handle uh pattern all right
so usually here we have the cap okay
here you have the handle so whenever you
have a breakout here usually the price
action goes higher the same length that
we have between the low of the cap and
the breakout level so here it's the
pattern is not perfect because here i'm
not touching but it is still good to use
so if we apply this rule we go from
three to seven so four points so it
would go to eleven okay so this is
roughly what we went yesterday okay if i
put it on the normal uh scale you can
see that the lengths are matching better
but i'm gonna keep the log scale
so here maybe we have reached the top
but i don't think so personally because
uh i don't have any resistance uh levels
in this area okay first thing here you
can see this is a woman's land when the
price action went down here it didn't
pull back at all on the upside so we
have here enormous land up to 24. okay
first information then i'm gonna connect
this with what i see on the synthetic
short interest you're gonna see how i
use this data
okay so any
get synthetic short bam okay
now so we have twenty percent of uh
maximum synthetic shot which is a lot
everything below five ten percent can
create some uh squeeze effect
then what you need to to do is to know
where this synthetic shot is coming from
to know if the if this momentum will
keep happening if we keep moving so
basically you are trying to locate the
gamma so here
to do that you check where those options
come from and i can see you know i have
here something easy the greener it is
the more options i have so here i can
see that it's coming from september the
biggest ones and it's coming from the 10
and 15 strike all right so
10 and 15 strike those two here on the
upside are coming from september all
right we went already through this one
so what does it uh tell us it tells us
that the six percent uh gamma which is
the difference of delta between the uh
synthetic short right now and the
synthetic shot if all the options are in
the money is gonna keep growing on the
upside and that's around the 10 level
market makers have a lot of gamma
because it's september and we are right
on it so the shorter the maturity the
more gamma there is just keep this in
mind so here september very explosive
and we have 10 and 15 so this is telling
me that market makers are still under
pressure here so now we come back to the
chart and what can we do here
so it's tough for me to get in now all
right okay this went too quickly here
you could have a stop limit order on the
upside it's a bit dangerous but it's the
best way to play the squeezes this is
the type of order we are having on
groupon for example in our live training
portfolio that we are sharing with you
guys on discord and this is the type of
folder we could have used here but it's
just we cannot do all the trades i've
seen this one and you know we didn't put
it in the portfolio we could have but
now we are not in this so the only thing
that we can do here is to use a support
level to enter so definitely 770 is a
support level so the type of trends that
i would do is like by around 778 and
stop loss below that so maybe below the
scandal this would make sense so the low
of the scandal is
660. so maybe a stop loss around 650
right so by 750 or 8 and stop 650 with a
target i don't think we're gonna go
right away to 24 because you can see the
gamma is stopping after 15 okay i don't
have any more strikes here everything is
empty all right so i don't think we're
going to reach 24
but maybe 15 or 20 something like this
this could be a good order second one
btcm so here
same situation we're having a breakout
this is a medium term breakout let's
check if the stock was bullish or
bearish it was renji so
now we have a bullish development
usually bullish developments occur in
five ways
as per elliot wave theory so here uh
it's hard for me same thing to know if
the third wave is complete or not maybe
if i zoom in i will see more information
here we have the breakout same thing
guys i didn't spot this one
unfortunately
so we are not in it but we had here a
nice situation
it was not easy to get in here but above
nine it was a nice level to get in so
let's see if i discuss this on my
discord
okay so i was discussing the short
interest so we had eight percent of
maximum short
and did they do an analysis i didn't do
any analysis on this one before so i
didn't see it so of course it's easy to
say but here was a nice entry
opportunity so now what can we do if you
guys want to play this move up here is
what i would do uh maybe i'm going to
set up this thread in the live training
portfolios this is supposed to be a
third wave all right so as we know
coming from the theory bam
yeah it's always the same thing i invite
you to go click on this link and read
all you can but if you are lazy just
read the 79th page okay
here this is telling you guys that uh
third wave they like to retrace one two
three four five top of the third the
bottom of the force is usually equal to
thirty eight point two percent
retracement of wave three so we're gonna
apply exactly this method here guys so
we measure wave three so for now it's
not complete okay so i don't know if
it's complete or not but if i have some
correction down to for example the 11
level i would know that probably the
third wave is here complete and this
could give me a level for the force wave
so here to me to be honest it's a bit
early to get in because we are not sure
the third wave is complete maybe it will
go higher so i would wait and i would
try to enter on the fourth wave so i
would wait for the third to be complete
i'm gonna post an alert on this in my
discord and i would be a buyer uh to
play the fifth wave guys uh so it
depends how quick things go but same
thing let's analyze here quickly the
synthetic short interest and let's see
how much time we have with this momentum
to be with us bam i retrieve the option
market okay so the synthetic shot has
not grown let's check where it's coming
from up bam the big ones this one
this one
so september 10 and 15 strike okay so we
have some bullish momentum on the upside
around 15 it's this one okay so this is
coming from september so same thing
there's going to be pressure until
september especially around 10 and 15 so
whenever we're going to cross 10 or
cross 15 there's going to be strong
moves because of the gamma and those
moves can happen only at the close
because market makers do hedge their
books at the close usually so you don't
need to have those moves right away so
here what happened we went through the
10 level i guess a very strong move so
if we arrive close to 15 level uh same
thing it might squeeze a bit more let's
see how how we go once again and on the
downside is true too so if you come
closer to the 10 level it will probably
accelerate so i would for sure not be a
buyer i would stop my position maybe
just below 10 okay because if we come
here there would be a lot of bearish
momentum for the same reason that we
move strongly on the upside we're going
to move strongly on the downside so this
is not ready for me to set up a trade i
would wait to see how high we go and
then i would try to enter using uh fibs
retracements and we're gonna use fibs
projections for the targets so this is
very indicative but it's gonna help us
to know where the stuff might go so
maybe one to one twenty or one to one
point six one eight according once again
to the elliott wave theory so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i plan anything new and stay close
to shore see you guys